[Musique]
d'où viennent les produits à combien de
kilomètres sont les produits comment on
nourrit aussi nos animaux c'est quand
même ce qui revient assez souvent des
questions que de plus en plus de
consommateurs se posent mais ici ils
peuvent enfin obtenir des réponses tour
de ferme c'est un magasin de producteur
pas d'intermédiaire donc les produits
élaborés et transformés dans un
périmètre de 80 km autour de tour sont
vendus dans ce local de jouer les tours
à l'origine neuf producteurs associés
qui souhaitent diversifier leur point de
vente on faisait déjà des marchés sur
nos fermes donc avoir tour de ferme bah
c'est un nouveau débouché c'est se
rapprocher de la ville puisquil y a
quand même un gros potentiel de clients
sur sur tour par rapport à chez nous au
fafond de nos campagnes et puis B c'est
se rapprocher des consommateurs les
producteurs viennent à tour de rôle à la
rencontre de leurs clients un concept
qui convient parfaitement à Françoise
productrice de porc dans l'Indre qui s'y
retrouve financièrement et humainement
c'est un bon complément parce que c'est
un surplu de production en vente directe
donc je trouve que c'est quand même plus
intéressant et par rapport au marchand
de bestiaux et puis ça fait quand même
une journée où voilà c'est sympa de
temps en temps de venir à la boutique et
de voir nos clients acheter local c'est
réduire les coût de transport mais aussi
faire vivre les fermes de la région par
exemple sur des fermes il y avait des
gens qui employaient des salariés à
mi-temps bah le fait d'avoir tour de
ferme maintenant c'est ils sont emploi à
temps plein il y a des gens qu' ont
recruté pour pouvoir fabriquer et pour
pouvoir vendre à tour de ferme donc
c'est une vraie dynamique d'emploi dans
nos campagnes et une dynamique d'emploi
ici puisqu'on a quand même quatre
salariés aujourd'hui donc on a un
directeur de magasin on a deux bouchers
à temps plein et une vendeuse à temps
plein pour ouvrir le magasin en novembre
2013 ils ont investi 220000 € chaque
mois il y a donc le loyer à payer le
remboursement de l'emprunt et les
salaires chaque producteur laisse donc
entre 20 et 30 % de ses recettes à tour
de ferme mais le jeu envoie la chandelle
puisque les clients sont au rendez-vous
le jour de l'ouverture 10 personnes
attendaient déjà devant la porte depuis
tour de ferme a su fidéliser sa
clientèle